في هذه الاثناء الغارات الاسرائيليه
متواصله على منطقه شرق المصدر كما تشاهدون
في هذه الصوره هذه غاره جويه اسرائيليه
على هذا المحور الشرقي لمنطقه المصدر
بالاضافه الى قبل قليل ايضا حدثت في هذه
المنطقه احزمه ناريه كبيره نفذتها ايضا
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه بالاضافه
الى على ما يبدو تقدما للقوات الاسرائيليه
في هذه المنطقه حدثت هناك عمليات اطلاق
نار مكثفه قبل قليل وايضا
عمليات عمليات تفجير في منطقه شرق المصدر
هذه اصابات وصلت مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في
دير البلح بعد قصف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لمنزل في المخيم الجديد بمخيم النصرات وسط
قطاع غزه هنا مازال الاطباء يتعامل مع عدد
من المصابين الذين يصلون من منطقه مخيم
الجديد في مخيم النصرات بعد غاره
اسرائيليه استهدفت منازل المواطنين هناك
وهناك عبا عن شهداء واصابات في المكان وصل
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى عدد من الشهداء جراء
غارات اسرائيليه على منطقه الزوايده
بالاضافه ايضا الى مخيم النصيرات وسط قطاع
غزه حيث اغارت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على عده منازل هذا الامر ادى
الى استشهاد عدد من المواطنين ووصلوا هنا
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح كنا كان قاعد فوق والله بتابع
الاخبار كنت قاعده جنبه انا وبناته نزلت
انا وبناته فيشي ع ثواني بالضبط ضربوه طب
ليش ضربتو قولوا لي ليش ضربتو ليش وجعته
قلبي ليش وجعته قلبي الغارات الاسرائيليه
متواصله على المحافظه الوسطى حيث يصل ما
بين الحين والاخر اعداد من المصابين
والشهداء هنا مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه لم
تتوقف تماما عن غاراتها الجويه على شرق
منطقه المصدر ومنطقه شرق المغازي بالاضافه
الى شرق مخيم البريج اشرف ابو عمره لقناه
الجزيره وسط قطاع غزه